what a do chat my name is ross panetta
chef and owner of five kitchen
and welcome to another episode of
celebrity recipe royale
on today's episode we're going to be
battling out two celebrity breakfast
sandwich recipes
on today's lineup we have gordon ramsay
and bts's very own
j-hope i measured out all the
ingredients as each recipe stated
and i found three breakfast sandwich
fanatics to help me find out which one
is the best now which one of these
celebrities has the best sandwich
let's get it cracking coming up to the
ring first is gordon ramsay he's gonna
start off by slicing his croissants in
half then he's gonna go ahead and heat
up a pan
throw a little bit of oil and salt for
seasoning once you brown up your salt a
little bit we're gonna go ahead and
toast our croissants since the
croissants
have so much butter in them already the
salt is gonna add that little bit of
extra flavor
once the croissants are done toasting
we're gonna put that to the side and
start working on the meat
in gordon ramsay's recipe he uses taso
ham since we ain't got that in queens he
says it's okay to use canadian bacon as
a substitute
so we're gonna go ahead and slice our
canadian bacon into thin strips
and fry them off be careful not to add
too much oil since canadian bacon
already has some fat in it be careful
when you're cooking your canadian bacon
because
if you overcook it it will be tough and
nobody want to be eating jerky
i mean so we're going to saute that for
a little while we're going to flip it so
we get some nice color
once that's done we're going to transfer
that to a paper lined bowl so you can
drain the fat from it
we trying to shed that covert weight you
know what i mean trying to look good
baby in that same pan you want to throw
in a little bit of oil and a little bit
of butter so that the butter don't burn
we're going to throw in some salt and
obey which is gordon ramsay's secret
weapon in this recipe
we're going to crack two eggs in and let
the residual heat cook off the eggs
so now that your eggs are cooking to the
side slowly we're gonna go ahead and
build our sauce by the way i forgot to
season the canadian bacon with a little
bit of peps in the pan but i'm gonna go
ahead and season in the bowl it's still
fine
in a bowl we're gonna take a couple
heaping tablespoons of mayo
a couple heavy dashes of your favorite
hot sauce
we're going to take this ginormous lemon
and squeeze it in to make the sauce
tangy
spicy and very saucy i like sauce next
up we're going to slice up our
accoutrements so we're going to go ahead
and thinly slice some tomatoes
and we're going to go ahead and cut some
lettuce make sure to take out the rib
from the lettuce because it's kind of
weird in a sandwich
now that your couch months are sliced
and to the side we're going to go ahead
and baste our egg so
we want to just set the egg white and
baste the yolk a tiny bit you still want
to have that nice
you know yolk porn you want to pop that
later on so now we're going to go ahead
and build our sandwich we're going to
take the bottom half of the croissant
put a little bit of sauce on the bottom
put on our lettuce a little bit of salt
in between tomato a little bit of salt
in between
canadian bacon we're going to go about
six or seven slices
we're gonna fold in our cheddar cheese
next we're gonna top that off
with our very nicely cooked egg some
more sauce
and finally the croissant top bang bang
there you have it cajun style breakfast
sandwich by gordon ramsay
we're going to close it on that sexy egg
and watch that yo pop
all right baby oh my god
this is made with a song so my initial
reaction to this one is i love a good
croissant
little bit of a soggy bottom here but
i will say the layers look delicious and
look at the sauce on this this has got a
lot of sauce
i don't like tomato though so i'm gonna
be rude and take off the tomato
cheese yes egg yes meat
yes this is the way to go when it comes
to breakfast sandwiches for real i would
have
liked to see maybe some sort of potato
layer
should i take a bite i'm going to take a
bite oh yeah
holy cow that's next level breakfast
stuff that's delicious
we got a nice little runny yolk on the
egg which is great
and honestly the fact that it's on the
croissant i think just elevates the
whole thing takes it out as well
some added crispiness would have been
nice but i love the
the flavor the sauce is amazing we have
some sort of
chipotle mayonnaise or some sort of hot
mayonnaise going on which i am a sucker
for a spicy mayo because you also get
like that juice from the tomato
that works very well with the bacon the
sauce everything wrapped up together
overall very good i would eat this
breakfast sandwich again
this is definitely something that i feel
like i would find at a more high-end
place
i would get this at a nice brunch i'm
guzzling down some mimosas this is just
kind of to fill my stomach so i don't
get too
tipsy this is gonna be hard to beat but
i think it's time to bring in the next
one all right so next up in the ring we
have j-hope from bts
he's gonna take two slices of bread and
lather them up with some butter he's
gonna take that
put it in a slightly oil pan and toast
them up real nice make sure your butter
is room temp so you can lather it up
evenly and not break your bread like i
did
once the bread is nicely toasted we're
gonna transfer that to a plate
and start cooking off our bacon you want
to make your bacon extra crispy like
you've been in the sun too long with no
tanning lotion all right while your
bacon is in the pan crisping up we're
going to go ahead and whisk
a couple of eggs make sure you flip your
bacon you want that nice all over even
tan
you want to drain some of the fat from
the bacon but we're also going to cook
the eggs in the remaining bacon fat
after you get a nice scramble you're
going to transfer that to a plate
and we're going to start building
j-hope's golden sandwich so we're going
to start off
by adding some extra butter we're going
to go ahead and throw on some blueberry
jam
that's actually his favorite then we're
gonna go ahead and layer on some slices
of bacon
and to top it off your fluffy golden
scrambled egg
and there you have it the most
attractive member on bts's golden toast
fight me on that one now right off the
bat this is looking pretty breakfasty
i'm very excited about this breakfast
sandwich because i
see jam i don't know how i feel about
this it looks like a blackberry jam
maybe in korea there's this like viral
street sandwich that has
egg cabbage spam but also jam
i love that combination sweet and salty
always a good mix
it smells mapley i like that time to
take a bite baby
this one was a little surprising because
it looks kind of elementary i'm not
going to lie i enjoyed that a lot more
than i thought i was going to
like this just makes me so happy the
sweetness of the jam
with the bacon and the egg is actually
really balanced and it's quite delicious
the bacon is just the right amount of
crisp
that fluffy egg on the top is tough this
is a good this is a
good little breakfast sandwich here i'm
really vibing with this whole jam i was
suspicious of the jam at first i didn't
think i was gonna like the jam but i'm
vibing with the jam
now which one of these celebrities has
the best sandwich let's
find out people this is a super tough
decision and that being said
i'm gonna go with number one final
answer
the croissant just really just took it
next level the sauce the quality of the
bacon and everything all in all
i had to be the one who's is it gordon
ramsay
again i think i've fixed gordon ramsay
last three times now but my man does not
disappoint
call me rosie
[Laughter]
my favorite breakfast sandwich of the
two would be
number two it just brought a smile to my
face
and it did remind me a lot of like the
street sandwiches back in korea
so definitely number two who is it oh my
god
oh i love that out of these two
celebrity sandwich recipes i've got to
say my favorite was surprisingly number
two
i didn't think i was gonna like jam on a
breakfast sandwich but
it was actually delicious it was
unexpected and i
really enjoyed it who made it okay well
that's cool i love bts i love kpop i
like to see artists
go outside of their usual area of
expertise
so i'm here for it well breakfast is
k-popping
cause j-hope takes today's celebrity
recipe royale so what other celebrities
do you guys want to see enter the
celebrity recipe royale arena
leave a comment below
you